[Applause]
yo did y'all see the candace owens cardi
b
beef yeah oh this [ __ ] is so funny
this is a tough one this [ __ ] is so it's
a tough one
why why is it so i can't fake taylor
what's your thoughts on uh
say what i said say it say that's it i
mean
all her points weren't that off who
candice
yeah candace is a bad [ __ ] girl she's
nice sorry
like i don't want to but if you look at
taylor's face can you please get the
taylor's face
please please taylor taylor okay yo you
got mad bullets in your gun use them
taylor it's okay
hold up hold up let me set it up cause
stop it stop it stop it stop it stop it
now but sometimes
you hear what you or she just said i
should shoot you because you're a
blessing
oh you shouldn't no but then sometimes
you gotta do it
i'm not doing that no okay so so here's
the let me just set it up for everybody
listening
that hasn't seen it yet okay candace
owens
is a troll she is the six
nine of right-wing politics yes and
she garners her fans by riling up
the opposition especially celebrities
that are in the opposition
that have dabbled in the political realm
candice is an
operative a tool used by the right okay
she can say all the things that the
extreme right cannot say
because a lot of times the extreme right
are old white guys
so old white guys cannot tell black
people to shut up about black lives
matter they cannot tell black people
cops don't kill them they cannot tell
black people that they need to
leave the democratic party because the
democratic party is the one that
enslaved them and they're just slaves
and being used
so they get a black female to do it so
that they cannot use her identity
against her
right because if a white guy said it
there'd be a lot of people just like oh
yeah you white male patriarchy shut the
[ __ ] up you're just racist
black woman does it you can't call her
you got to call her a sell out you got
to call her a [ __ ] or whatever the [ __ ]
it is right
so she is on ben shapiro's show and she
calls out cardi b for being i guess a
liberal shill
yeah yeah which she is now
cardi she's saying is being used by the
democrats
which she is and she says it's insulting
to black people's intelligence
and it's she says insulting black
people's intelligence
i think that's debatable now here's the
thing
it's okay to be used if you want to be
used for that in other words
any employer is using an employee
if that employee wants to be used for
that job that's a beautiful relationship
what did you just say candace owens is
she is a shill for the republican party
100 if candace owens was a white man
she would be out of a job 100 percent
owens is
nothing without her identity yeah she
would be another political pundit
she'd be rush limbaugh or one of these
other guys that would just be
thrown out to the fray and call the
racist and been told to shut the [ __ ] up
but she is a lightning rod because of
her identity nobody
benefits from identity politics more
than candace owens yeah and she is the
one that's trying to push back against
identity politics identity politics goes
away you don't have a job candace and
she knows this
in the same way the right uses candace
the left
uses children to make their arguments so
they use
greta thundberg for the environment
throw a little girl out there
right-wing people don't want to
criticize a little girl throw
those kids that were in the school
shooting throw them out there and tell
them not to tell people not to use guns
that's the last people you can argue
with not the la you're not going to
argue with some kids that work in a
school shooting
right so you every political side
uses these operatives candace is making
a true point which is
cardi's being used cardi is saying yeah
i want to be used yeah i align with
these political
uh viewpoints yeah candace is saying
you don't know what they are and her
point
when she kind of uh i guess executed it
a little bit further is like
you say you want to save money in taxes
you say you want to do i think she had a
couple other things on her agenda cardi
b
yeah and it's like all those things kind
of line up with the republican platform
yeah not the democratic one so candace
went about it in this like dragging
culture type of way we're like i'm going
to criticize you i'm going to make fun
of you i'm going to have the
the timeline going oh you got lit on
fire ooh whatever
but the points that she was making about
cardi and
when she articulated what cardi is
saying she wants and how the democratic
party does not service that
could stand up absolutely but to say
that she's just being used it's like
yeah well candace so you're being used
by prager university you're being used
like of course everybody here is being
used
and are people pandering yes donald
trump is pandering
cardi b is pandering joe biden exactly
like donald trump
doesn't have kim kardashian at the white
house and kanye west at the white house
everybody's pandering it's election
season baby it's time to tap dance yeah
that's what everybody's doing and we are
going to tap dance on the biggest
[ __ ] platforms
100 and that that was the only thing
that
so all the points you just made i agree
with
and cardi pushed back on like oh
they're not just speaking to me to
pander to
the black vote and i disagree because
that's the only reason why they would
speak to cardi b
yes there's that's the only reason it's
just a pander to your fans and the
majority of your fans
are black people who listen to hips yes
yes the best response would have been
you're just as much of a tool as me
that's just that's what this is yeah
yeah if cardi
clapped back that way i would have been
good but i'm just saying what candy said
isn't wrong
it's not wrong you they are trying to
get
black people to vote for biden
that's why he has kamala too and that's
why he has kamal as well
that is a pandering move yeah now the
line
between pander and service and
representation
is very thin right yeah i want
in this movie okay let's put an indian
person in this movie are we pandering to
indians are we pandering to the left or
are we representing them
the right wing would say you're
pandering the left wing would say this
is progress is representation
they can mean the same thing but you're
both doing it and everybody's [ __ ]
doing it
yeah literally everybody's trying to use
it
so is it necessarily bad i don't know is
candace right that cardi has probably
very limited knowledge of the political
sphere
yeah sure i haven't seen
can uh cardi say anything that was like
wildly prolific when it came to politics
have you guys
no i don't even think i could take it
seriously if she did i'm just so used to
old cardi you start talking like really
thought out points i'd be like this is
different
yeah she's like i pay millions dollars
in taxes i don't want to pay as much in
taxes well yeah okay you're a republican
or you're everyone actually yeah no one
wants to pay money in taxes
yeah you know so i i completely
understand but this is just like
this is classic candace and i don't
understand why people fall for it i know
like why would cardi fall for it she
just does this all the time people
always get it
everybody falls for trolls if you're a
sports man bayless means nothing he says
why do we fall for these people you know
what it shows in security yeah it's like
real security would be you can
excuse me real security is somebody's
talking [ __ ] about you you know that
that thing isn't true so you don't
respond to it right
cannon struck a nerf and the nerve was
and this is my assumption i don't know
cardi b my assumption is
cardi felt candace was right yeah or her
insecurity about her political knowledge
or how she's being used etc
the only reason you respond to criticism
is because you believe that criticism
about yourself
or it is so abs absurdly wrong
it's not even the sphere of reality and
even in those situations you're like i
don't dignify that with a response yeah
charlotte may ask diddy
yo did you have biggie killed or
whatever it is or poop tupac killed
remember and did he's like i'm not even
gonna dignify that with a response
so honestly it's like stop falling for
this [ __ ]
i don't understand it why do people get
caught every time
tommy larum would do the same thing she
said one thing black twitter go crazy
we did it to black twitter i didn't
think this would even work i didn't even
mean it
when we were like who's black or adele
or beyonce
it's a it is the most obvious joke
no it is blacker than beyonce even more
obviously it's a more obvious joke
did you see that last week we said adele
is more is blacker than beyonce
and then we start going through all
these reasons why okay like adele the
name is blacker than beyonce like we
just saw
every reason like it was abs it was the
most absurd in the world like who makes
better mac and cheese like all these
absurd things
there were blue check marks on twitter
debating about how toxic this was how
problematic this was
i couldn't believe it i couldn't believe
it
and all you're doing is making us more
famous theoretically like that's why
not that we did but candace owens if she
just existed and black twitter wasn't up
in arms
she just exists tommy lahren i i feel
like i watched it happen where i heard
about her once or twice
and then all of a sudden she just became
this thing because everybody would get
outraged by whatever she said
there's no substance to what she's
saying yeah let a crazy person rant on
the side of the street if you give if
you get offended by every
crazy person on the subway saying crazy
[ __ ] you just make them more powerful
mm-hmm let them live
let them go away ignore them yeah yeah
i mean candace is just going to
gravitate towards where the money is
and there will always be money for
a person of the opposite race
willing to criticize their own there
will be money for white people
that are willing to trash white people
on behalf of minorities
and there will be money for minorities
that are willing to trash
minorities on behalf of white people
yeah because you need those trojan
horses out there
and the more upset you get by them the
more their people
give them power because they're like i
love how much he pisses off black people
i love it i love it we got to keep
supporting this girl she's the best
if you just didn't give a [ __ ] she just
exists and nobody really cares and you
know it's
you know it's a real shame i think about
candace is that like
she is a product of outraged culture
but she's a very eloquent and smart one
yes and she's got star power and she's
[ __ ] brave
that woman is exactly or just use that
power for
regardless of its good or not justice
not outrage
like like not lowest common denominator
like going after
cardi b like what like don't you have
bigger fish to fry like go after
corporate maniacs
go after yeah you can go after clinton
you can go after there's so many
different things
you can go after i guess like but she
does that for the same reason six nine
does it
right i'm sure 69 is like yo i can make
really catchy songs but nobody's gonna
listen unless i tattoo
four you know for the clovers on my face
and i start beef with everybody in
chicago then they listen so
unfortunately i gotta do that
but if but if you could just make the
catchy songs if we rewarded that
that's what they would do and i bet you
if we rewarded
candace just having like a nuanced
opinion about politics that just
happened to be right wing but it wasn't
on race and it wasn't necessarily about
race and and
matter of fact by not mentioning race
she might get way more black people to
go
huh that person looks like me and she's
making really good points and she's not
calling everyone disagrees with her
[ __ ] sellout or [ __ ] or whoever they
call her that [ __ ] on the same thing but
like
it's like we're the the outreach culture
we exist in
is making us lose people that could be
like really effective and talented
yeah and and that's not our fault only
it's their fault for falling for it
you know what i'm saying like we could
play the lowest comments in our
denominator every saturday when we do
those pieces we don't
we take a nuanced point of view yeah
yes you gotta [ __ ] be willing to
sacrifice i don't know it is a much
quicker path but i think the ceiling is
lower
yes because she goes where she evokes a
strongest response which is obviously a
black woman criticizing black people
and that evokes such a strong response
it is a fast track to the middle
yeah to the middle that's better said
fast track to the middle
the ceiling greatness is people who
build and
try to be nuanced and in the end that
wins but she is fast tracking her
way to the [ __ ] candice can't be in
politics no
now eventually maybe she can do the ben
shapiro pivot where ben sparrow was like
super antagonistic to black people and
now he's like i'm just a regular nuanced
republican right it's like
but because he realized he's in the
middle he's stuck in the middle exactly
i can only go so far with this
so can is gonna have her pivot and then
i guess i would say to any of the
candice like detractors
i would go keep that same energy with
her and remember remind her to keep that
same energy
yeah when she she will make that pivot
she's not a critical mass but she's
going to make that pivot where it's just
like
once her protectors and the people
paying her or go
okay you're famous enough where you
actually kind of like need to be a
little bit more mainstream
welcome everybody in the fray a little
bit more she will make that pivot and
just remind her
hey you were just as bought as the
people that you were saying are also
bought yeah there's gonna be time where
she needs black moderates to vote
and she's gonna have to back off and
then yeah remind her no that's
you got here with this [ __ ] you sit in
that